Film Courage: We touched on some excellent
points on the right way to start screenwriting.
Let's talk about the wrong way to start.
Writer/Instructor and Script Consultant
Shannan E. Johnson (The Professional Pen):
Oh that's the question?
Film Courage: Yeah that's a question sorry…
Shannan: No it's okay, it's okay. I think the
wrong way to start is just assuming you know how
this thing works right? Assuming that you know
what screenwriting is and so you don't have to
do any research, that you don't have to try to
hone your craft in any way, that you don't have
to read any screenplays, that you can just wake
up and write. Even though I said earlier writing
is a part of it, that's the first thing you want
to do, you want to start getting your ideas out to
see what they are right but then to assume that
that's all it takes is the wrong place to start
it's also the wrong place to start to assume that
you don't have to know anything about the business
right as writers you're your own advocate you are
your business and you're walking into a business
so as much as it's creative there's also the
business part of it and so you can have the best
screenplays out there but if you don't know how to
play this game of getting into the business then
you're not going to be in the right mindset of
it um and also assuming that you're just going to
be able to jump right in right like there is like
there's no uh putting in the midnight oil you know
what I mean of realizing that this is long game
this Hollywood thing is long game so going back
to that networking across thing right five years
from now 10 years from now all of those people are
going to be in different places not two days from
now so the same thing is true with your writing
it's a process so going back to knowing the
business realizing that I can write a screenplay
today and it might not get made until seven years
from now right so realizing that it's not a quick
thing it's not an in and out you know kind of
machine which is why you have to ask yourself
what is it that I want from this what is my end
goal am I trying to be a professional writer
am I just trying to get this one thing done and
if that if it's only that one thing do I really
want to put the time and energy into doing it
another place uh that you shouldn't start from
is thinking that the writer has total creative
control right this is a collaborative effort
filmmaking is so realizing that there will always
be someone critiquing your work always always
always always and then learning how to separate
yourself from that so you aren't taking taking
it personally a no to your work is not a no to you
as a person like take that in you know breathe it
understand it that no to your work may mean this
is not the right work for our company it may mean
this is not what we're looking for right now it
may mean there's growth necessary on your part
that's good information to hear you want to hear
great I need to grow because now you know what to
you know what to work towards versus not hearing
anything at all because that happens in Hollywood
too where people just don't respond to you at all
you don't get anything right but getting that no
tells you I now am open to try to sell this
somewhere else this wasn't the right fit for
it and getting that information so I know a lot
of people uh say you need tough skin when you
come into this um this industry and yes that may
be true but if you can learn how to disconnect
from your work equaling your worth right then the
tough scan is not necessary as much because you
know that they're not critiquing you right they're
talking about what's on the page and when someone
else develops it or someone else purchases
it they're now trying to get it to fit the
mold of their brand which is why you have to do
your research at the first place to ask yourself
is this the best place for my baby is this the
best place for my story right if you decide to
pitch something to nbc it's got to feel like nbc
so that means the executives are going to mold it
into nbc that means they might lose trim some of
the stuff that you think is very important it may
mean that they're going to add some stuff that you
never thought about that's going to make this the
best show to ever hit television so you have to
be open to that collaborative process so I think
those three or four things are really important
that if you're not understanding that you're
starting off in the wrong place can you have thick
skin tough skin and not be callous yes I think so
i think that thick skin that people are talking
about is being able to receive feedback not take
it personally and then therefore not react from
an emotional place and start to burn bridges
with that being said there are plenty
of callous people in the industry
a lot of the people who tell people they need to
have tough skin don't have tough skin themselves
right everyone is sensitive you know and
in the world that we live in right now
everyone is sensitive and then you come into an
industry where um we are creating things and like
Erykah Badu said people are sensitive about their
stuff right so I think that thick skin just really
comes from a place of understanding that this
is not about you and it's about the work and the
stuff but you are going to deal with all kinds of
different personalities just like you would in any
kind of industry there are people who are not so
nice here right there are people who are rude here
and then there are people who aren't and there
are people who want to help you and they're
people who want you to grow but at the end of
the day you're still going to hear no more than
more than you hear yes right someone does have
to approve and accept and affirm the thing that
you're giving to them and oftentimes you're not
going to hear the thing you wanted to hear and
if you don't know how to disconnect if you don't
know how to grow that tough skin that they say
then it can start to chip away at who you
are right um and that should not be um the
end goal so yeah I think you can definitely have
tough skin and not end up being a callous person
but it takes work you know it takes work and then
you also said not knowing the industry so if I
want to jump in one of the wrong ways is to not
do research on the industry and who i'm pitching
and different things like that what if I say you
know what i'm just really good at winging it i've
always been good at sports I can fit into any room
i'm a chameleon in some ways I don't really need I
can just just get me there and and i'll i'll know
who's in charge yeah I have a radar for that do it
try it out because at the end of the day no one
has the same true Hollywood story right everyone
gets into this industry in a different way so if
that's your strong suit getting into the room and
selling yourself the hard part is getting into
the room right when you get in there let your
personality shine you know do the thing that
works for you because nine times out of ten if
that works for you in other places it'll work
for you here as long as whatever it is you're
saying can actually be backed up by what's on the
page a lot of people think what's on the page is
fantastic and wonderful and it just isn't right so
now you went into the room and you oversold right
you went into the room and you said I have this
thing and then we read this thing and it's like
no you don't right so making sure that you're not
going to oversell because now people are going to
remember that you may not be able to get into the
room the next time but other than that if you're
a winged kind of person wing it the question is
how do you get in the room in the first place in
order to wing it that's why you have to know about
the industry do you ever see that where someone
who's kind of underconfident they actually have
really excellent work yeah and it's the ones that
are like beating the the chest and wait you just
gotta see and it's like might not be there yet
almost always it's almost always that and I say
almost because there are outliers but it's almost
always that usually the people you know the
more introverted more i'm not really sure you
know what's happening here you read their stuff
and it's like you got something here you can be
confident about that and then it's the people who
say I know I have this thing you read it and it's
like you don't know how to format a scene heading
so no you don't have this thing you know quite
yet so yes it happens all the time and this is not
necessarily an industry that expects people to be
humble you know what I mean so I don't I don't
my I don't mock them for being overconfident
however that thing on the page is what represents
you period it doesn't matter what's coming out
of your mouth you know what I mean so you have to
be able to back it up which is why I said earlier
you need that other set of eyes you need someone
you can trust on your team as a script consultant
that's what I become I become a part of your team
everybody needs a script consultant even if they
don't know that we exist right but once you find
someone you need someone who can objectively look
at your stuff and let you know if you're doing
the thing you intend to do good or bad right and
if we don't have those checks and balances then
all we have is our own confidence all we have is
our own ego and you can sometimes oversell um
what you have going on but I don't think your
overconfidence is bad you know what I mean you
know I would rather that than you falling apart
because you get a no you know what I mean but
really trying to make sure that whatever it is
you're selling can be seen on the page is the most
important thing there are plenty of people walking
around Hollywood with egos we have a lot of those
so i'm not going to say you can't have an ego sure
you can you know what I mean but you got to be
able to back it up well what if I say though you
know I ran this by my brother-in-law and he owns
his own company and this guy he knows his stuff
so it's already good I already know that yeah
does he know screenwriting no but he's built a
business and he's very successful look at the end
of the day i'm always going to say try it try it
go with it send your screenplay to one of these
script coverage companies send your screenplay to
me send it to a competition send it to a film
festival and see what happens right because
maybe you're right i'm not going to say that you
don't have natural talent I have natural talent
right i've sent screenplays out that haven't been
looked at you know by other people and they've
done decently well so I can't say that that won't
happen for another person but at the end of the
day you want someone who understands not only
the industry but also understands uh writing
you know understands the medium of screenplays
so that they can give you actual criticism and
critique if not then it's just opinion right
like you can have your mom or your dad or your
brother read as much as you want they'll like it
or don't won't like it but can they tell you why
can they tell you how to fix things or are they
just giving more opinion and everybody out there
has got an opinion it doesn't mean that it's
going to make your story better so if you feel
that you don't need another set of eyes totally
fine put it out in the into the universe and
see if you get what you need in return and if you
don't then you'll have to change your tactic just
like your characters have to do you know when
they aren't getting the things that they need.
Questions For The Viewers: What were the big
mistakes you made when you started screenwriting?